As far as inputs are concerned, inputs acceptable to an abstract
specification must also be acceptable to the concrete implementation. However,
the refined operations, that is the implementation, can accept more.
This might happen if for example you use a particular library routine
that's very general to deal with satisfying some con,
some abstract need. Okay, you can accept more inputs, but
it has to accept at least as many as the abstract one requires of us.
In terms of our specification stated more precisely, refinements can weaken
operation preconditions. And in logic where every, concrete state T, if
the invariant is true an the, preconditions are true in the abstract state, then
it better be the case that the preconditions are true in the concrete state.